hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast innovators of NSD -
discovered by high-throughput screening
with the nucleosome substrate presented
by nathan cousins senior research
scientist biology division of
preclinical innovation national center
for advancing translational sciences
National Institute of Health I'm Alexis
Krause of lab rats and I'll be your
moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
lappers labyrinths is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before you begin I'd like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
question into the drop down box that
appears on the screen once there's many
of your questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know if you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
cousins I will now turn the presentation
over to him thank you for the
introduction Alexis and welcome to the
webinar today I'll talk about inhibitors
of the human histone lysine
methyltransferases
called MSC two that were discovered at
in cats using quantitative
high-throughput screening with the
full-length wild-type enzyme and a
nucleosome substrate and I'll begin by
giving you some introduction and
background to the project I'll talk
about Hasse development and I can put
screening that led to the identification
of a number of hits and then I'll talk
about different counter screens and
assays used to further triage the hits
we
and I'll focus on five inhibitors that
we identified and some follow-up studies
that we performed I'll tell you about
some of the conclusions that we have and
some of the future directions we are
pursuing so this work was done at the
NIH chemical genomics Center which was
founded in 2004 and was the first Center
in the molecular library screening cell
center network and this was part of a
large NIH roadmap initiative intended to
bring small molecule Discoverer Sciences
to academic and government collaborators
and currently we have more than 200
collaborators located throughout the
world and we focus on ask a development
high-throughput screening chemical
informatics and medicinal chemistry to
go from targets to lead molecules but
our focus is really on unprecedented
targets and rare and neglected diseases
so the mission of our Center is to
catalyze the generation of innovative
methods and technologies that will
enhance the development testing and
implementation of interventions that
tangibly improve human health across a
wide range of human diseases and
conditions and my colleagues and I
focused on a variety of aspects
throughout the discovery pipeline or
presented at the top of this slide from
the point of initial validation of a
target for potential small molecule
modulator to the development of assays
that can be used in high-throughput
screening to identify hits among large
libraries of chart like compounds and
then these compounds that show up as
heads can be further optimized using
medicinal chemistry to improve their
selectivity potency and efficacies and
then used as chemical probes to further
understand the underlying biology or
advanced into preclinical development
and we can take projects as far as Basel
and clinical trials
through our therapeutics for rare and
neglected diseases program or transit so
today I'll give you an example of one
such project that was in our pipeline
and is and so this involves a protein
that's been associated with multiple
names and diseases and I'm actually
bringing
he's in from multiple labs throughout
the slides in the stack so I wanted to
introduce all three names so that you
won't be confused by the different
nomenclature so one of the first names
for this protein was WH SC one due to
its involvement in Wolff Hirsch wine
syndrome which is due to a partial
deletion from the short arm of
chromosome 4 and this is one of the
genes that's deleted and so it was
termed wolf Hirshhorn syndrome candidate
one so another name for the same protein
is NS C 2 which I will preferentially
use throughout this talk and that stands
for nuclear receptor binding site domain
protein 2 and it belongs to a family of
histone lysine methyltransferases that
are called nuclear receptor binding site
between proteins and as you can see this
involves NS c 1 ms c 2 and NS d 3 and
these three genes are associated with
multiple gene products and they're named
or there's catalytic set domain this
indicated in red on the slide so this
set domain is responsible for the methyl
transferase activity and they also
contain a variety of domains important
for molecular interactions for instance
the protein tryptophan tryptophan
prolene domain is important for
identification of the nucleosomes
substrate and document the enzyme so
what's the ants I'm binds to the
nucleosome substrate so NS C 2 can
utilize as a methyl donor s
adenosylmethionine to either mono or
dine methylate has from 3 lysine 36 and
one of the products of this reaction is
s-adenosyl el homocysteine or saw so
I'll refer to these molecules of salmon
SOG throughout this talk so the NF C
enzymes have been implicated in cancers
and really subscribe to act as uncle
proteins through the dye methylation of
lysine 36 on histone 3 this alters the
gene expression
and increases the expression of
oncogenes and this brings us to our
third name for this protein which is mm
set for multiple myeloma said domain and
so this protein was initially associated
with 15 to 20 percent of multiple
myeloma is that have this chromosomal
translocation the results in a fusion
transcript between the immunoglobulin
heavy chain and NS C 2 and so this
causes over expression of Emma C 2 in
these cell lines which you can see in
this western blots on the left-hand part
of the glide are multiple myeloma cell
lines that contain this chromosomal
translocation and you can see the
increase in NSC to expression and as you
would expect based on my introduction
you can also see an increase in h3k
30-60 methylation compared to the cell
lines on the right that did not contain
this chromosomal translocation so as you
would expect if you use shrna to reduce
the concentration of NS C 2 you get a
corresponding reduction in h3k 36 time
ethel ation and that's also seeing if
you knock out NSC 2 from the cell line
and then on the right side you can see
that as you would expect if you add and
has B to back into the cell line you yet
again started to see this page 30k 36
that methylation so MSC 2 was initially
described as a protein over expressed in
multiple myeloma cancers but it was
since that time reported to be
associated with a variety of other human
cancers the over expression of NS C 2
but not only NSC - over expression has
been associated with cancer but also
point mutations that increase the
catalytic activity events and one such
mutation is a tec-9 m'kay which was
identified in myeloma and a ll and you
can see that that point mutation occurs
in the set domain the catalytic site the
meaning of Tennessee - and it's sad that
it increases the association between
enzyme and the headstone substrate and
if you look at the plaque on the lower
left side in the slide you can see that
the in vitro activity of this mutant
Tennessee 2 is higher than the
corresponding Wildside counterpart and
as you would expect it results in
increased levels of h3k 3610 methylation
as you can see in the western black and
increased transformation of multiple
myeloma cell lines that Express the e
1099 K mutation compared to wild-type
enzyme so if you decrease the
concentrations of the e10 99k point
mutant by using shrnas it results in
lower proliferation of celsa Express
this mutant enzyme compared to the wild
type cells it also reduces the amount of
colony formation and in subcutaneous
xenograft models it reduces the size of
the tumor volume the tumor volume in
áall cells so Mass Effect studies have
demonstrated increased h 3q 3610
methylation in both multiple myeloma and
a ll cell lines that expresses even
Tennessee - compared to the wild side
counterpart and as you would expect
based on the introduction this increased
catalytic activity is associated with an
alteration and gene expression compared
to the wild type counterpart so that's
not the only point mutations been
identified another one G 1150 a was
identified in mantle cell lymphoma and
it again is located at the catalytic
site domain and as you can see on the
right the in-vitro activity of this
mutant enzyme is a higher compared with
the wild-type counterpart
so in summary NF C 2 has been trying to
act as a general uncle protein in
transformation assays and as catalytic
activity is required for its two region
isset e it promotes the expression of
oncogenes and many cancer types are
associated with NS d 2 over
expression including many that I'm
listening on the slide there are
clinically relevant NSD point mutations
which increase its catalytic activity
but are also associated with cancer so
that therapeutic hypothesis is if we can
identify small molecule inhibitors of NS
C 2 it would be beneficial for some
cancer patients however NS C 2 has been
a very difficult enzyme to identify
inhibitors of and this has been
published for instance in the study that
I'm showing it for the article that I'm
showing at the bottom of this slide but
also in discussions with my colleagues
at work in Pharma I'm aware that this is
a very difficult target and the many
pharma companies are working on this
enzyme so there are very few reports of
inhibitors for NS t 2 and I'm
summarizing them on the slide at the top
left is le mo 6 that was discovered from
virtual screening against an NS v 2
homology model and it was followed up in
vitro going found to have a very weak
potency of almost a millimolar the
mycotoxin keto Singh is known as a
nonspecific methyl transferase inhibitor
it inhibits all on the MSD enzymes and
inhibits NSE to at low micro molar
concentrations on the sanik the same
analog sent fungating that's isolated
from streptomyces is a fairly weak
inhibitor an NS t 2 and the
anti-parasitic drug called sermon is
known to inhibit NS t 2 but it's also
known as a an inhibitor of methyl
transferases so none of these molecules
have the attributes of a high quality
chemical probe for instance such as a
defined mechanism of action and
selectivity towards NS T 2 so this is
what we would like to identify I
mentioned the NF C 2 has been a very
difficult target to identify inhibitors
up and this is partially because it
requires whole nucleosomes as a
substrate and so some of the data in the
slide demonstrate that at the left you
can see that native histones purified
from HeLa either in the context of
nucleus
or and lacking the DNA so in the context
of ACTA MERS are substrates for amnesty
to now MSC to methylates histone 3 as
expected in the context of nucleosomes
however you see that the substrate
specificity actually switches over in
the case of optimist that lack that DNA
has done for which is madness
never really known to be physiologically
relevant so seems that the
physiologically relevant modification is
to histone 3 so NFC to really needs to
methylene nucleosomes and this is
actually confirmed using recombinant
histones you can see this same pattern
in the data shown in the middle where n
SC two's methylating histone 3 in the
context of nucleosomes but it's on 4 and
the context of octamer x' however you
can see that the activity is a bit lower
with recombinant histones and inside the
business due to currently
uncharacterized post translational
modifications that make the new the
native histones a more a more capable
substrate for honesty too and then the
data on the right just show the
selectivity antibody used for these
studies if the lysine is mutated to
alanine
you're no longer able to sustain that
h3k 36 die methylation no several groups
have reported that NFC's are not active
against peptide substrates and this has
been somewhat of a hindrance to
developing assays for high-throughput
screening of course peptides are
excellent substrates particularly for
high-throughput screening assays our
group has also found that at least our
wild-type full-length NS c 2 is not
acted against the peptide substrates a
need examined I'm taking some text from
the publications shown at the bottom
that indicated the in addition to the
lack of activity against peptide
substrates
at least in 2014 there was also a lack
of robust quantitative assays that can
be used for screening of n SDS to
identify inhibitors and
fortunately the situation there has
changed as I'll talk about at
momentarily but this had been a barrier
for quite some time so there are two
relevant studies in the literature for
high throughput screening of the NSD
enzymes the first one involves two
catalytic set domain of NS t 2 and
utilizes a nucleosome substrate as a
assay they used two radio labeled Sam
and this was conducted in 384-well
format and these authors create more
than a thousand compounds from the press
what chemical library at a single
concentration of 25 micromolar and they
identified sermon as a hit now a related
report involved the NSC 2's relative NSC
1 again a fragment of NS c1 and a
histone octamer substrate and they
utilize a sensitive luminescence based
assay and it was performed in 3d for
well format and they screamed more than
1,700 compounds of micro sources
spectrum collection again at a single
concentration of 20 micro molar and
identified sermon as a hit ok so we
realized that we had used native
histones in the context of nucleosomes
substrate in order to identify
inhibitors of NS C 2 but one of the
things that we realized that we could
contribute is that we have the ability
at MCATs to miniaturize assays - 1536
level format and that can really allow
you to stretch the reagents that you
have quite a bit further for example on
the left part of the slide I'm showing
you a 96-well plate a 384-well plate in
1536 lovely and of course they all have
the same footprint but in the space of
i-96 well you can see that in a 384 well
plate there are war wells in a 1536 well
played we'd have 16 wells in that same
space so if you wanted to perform a
titration of seven points with 50 micro
litre Williams in 96 weld format it
would require
350 microliters however you could
perform that same experiment with only
20 microliters in a 1536 law format so
it really allows you to stretch
by your use of the reagents and I
mentioned two relevant studies that
utilize the 384-well format for
screening and if those authors wanted to
screen a hundred thousand compounds that
would require two hundred sixty-one
plates whereas if the same screen was
conducted with 1536 one format it only
requires 66 microtiter plates so one of
the things that we did was to
miniaturize the assay down to four
microliters the next thing is that we
really were lucky that kromega had just
released the methyl transferase glow
acid and that involves performing the
methyl transferase reaction and solution
so in our case it was full-length
wild-type Emma C 2 with nucleosomes
purified from HeLa and as you know I
described in the introduction in
addition to methylating the nucleosomes
Sam is converted to saw and the way this
detection technology works is that Saad
is then through a two-step process first
converted to ATP and then from ADP to
ATP and then luminescent light through a
Lucifer's temple reaction so um this is
a very sensitive readout and had a
number of advantages among the common
detection technologies you could see
that as I mentioned luminescence is the
most sensitive detection methodology
also luminescence is less susceptible to
some types of compound mediated
interferences as shown in the slide here
so for instance compounds can use
aggregation they can have components
specific interferences such as unwanted
activity due to chemical reactivity they
can have molecular mimicry they can
interfere with an assay and they can
also through autofluorescence properties
for absorbance they can interfere with
luminescent readouts and that's shown
sorry fluorescence readout so it's shown
on the left and work at our center
demonstrated that if you're able to
redshift you are fluorescence based
assay
you can reduce the amount of
interference of these library compounds
but with luminescence you don't have
that initial excitation energy so you
know you have far less compounds that
are interfering to to that mechanism
although you can have compounds that are
absorbing a luminescent light from the
luciferase so we have to be aware of
that and another source of asking
interference is that these compounds
could potentially inhibit the coupling
enzymes the couple the saw product to
the luminescent light I'll come back to
them okay so I mentioned two different
assets that were reported in the
literature and the involves screening at
a single concentration single dose and
the question is how do you know whether
your assay is suitable for I through
what screening and historically people
used different metrics to evaluate the
performance of assays and suitability
for high-throughput screening including
metrics like signal to noise and signal
to background and I'm showing you two
examples of assays on the left with
their high and low signals indicated by
solid lines the mean and then you can
see the data points are distributed as
noise around the mean and if I asked you
which assay was better suited for
high-throughput screening to give you
that confidence in screening single
doses and you use the signal-to-noise or
signal to background you would prefer
the assay on the bottom because it has a
superior signal or background and
signal-to-noise ratio however your eyes
are probably telling you the VSA at the
top is better and you're right because
there's more separation between the high
and low signals so if you look at some
of the data points that are near the
threshold and the high signal in the
bottom assay you can see they they
almost look like hits that they're still
in the range of noise and where's on the
top there's a lot more separation
between these two populations and so
hits are easier to really have
confidence in and so this is indicated
by the C prime factor equation that's
shown at the bottom right and so
basically this fits into
count three standard deviations around
the high control and the low control and
gives you a sense of the separation
between these two populations and so in
theory a perfect assay would have as a
prime factor value of one
but in practice an assay with the C
prime vector value of 0.5 or greater is
considered to be an excellent assay in
an assay with the Z prime vector less
than zero is basically impossible for
screening so we let me try and start NSC
two reaction data for microliters and
optimize it with the methyltransferase
flow assay and using the full-length
wild-type and a situ enzyme and a
nucleosomes substrate and then evaluated
the performance and what we found was
that it was excellent with the Z prime
factor of 0.9 and signaled a background
higher than 3 as you can see on the left
of this slide one of the things that we
have to be concerned about n cats is
whether DMSO can interfere with readout
because all of our test compounds are
delivered what DMSO is a vehicle so we
carried out a demon so titration as you
can see in the middle and show the edema
so is it reducing our signal window and
then we also wanted to be sure that as
you would expect if you lower the
concentration of the enzyme you see a
linear reduction in the signal and that
was the case so given the excellent
performance of this passe we then
optimize two assays for it the two
clinically relevant mutants that I
described in the introduction eat n 99 K
and T 11:50 a and as you can see these
assays were very similar in their
performance compares the biotype enzyme
with C prime values close to point nine
and signal the background values of
three okay so this is the protocol
sequence that we used for
high-throughput screening again we
miniaturized these assays down to four
microliter volumes we delivered test
compounds as 23 Nana litre a loquats
and the methyl transferase reaction
proceeded for 15 minutes
temperature before we initiated the
detection sense so on the left side of
the slide is a schematic showing the
high throughput screening facilities in
cats you can see that we have a variety
of different plate readers liquid
handlers incubators and care cells to
hold test compounds and three robots
that collectively are able to reach all
the instrumentation throughout the
platform and so they coordinate the
screens and can actually perform
multiple spy throughput screens at the
same time depending on the needs for the
instrumentation and one of the
contributions of n cats so the high
throughput screening community is the
introduction of quantitative
high-throughput screening which is when
a throughput screening is performed at a
dose response format and then this
really allows us to make excellent
decisions on which prioritizing it
compounds of which are the most
attractive to follow online because
right out of the primary screen we have
information about potency advocacy
sometimes information that might select
suggest that a certain compound is some
type of an assay artifact but the way
that this is a executed is pretty pretty
excellent for flexibility so for
instance we have all the compounds and
their different concentrations located
on separate plates so if you wanted to
perform a high-throughput screen at a
single concentration not only could you
do that you can decide which
concentration you wanted to screen at
but if you wanted to screen a
dose-response format you can choose the
number of titration points you wanted to
use and the concentrations so it really
gives you a lot of flexibility for this
particular project we screen eight
libraries including the library
pharmacologically active compounds for
low PAC the preswick chemical library
the micro solar source collection the
tokers collection an epigenetics focused
collection that was too
in cats a natural products library and
and what's called an impact library
which contains a number of compounds
with known mechanisms and then the
famous and cats pharmaceutical
collection which includes more than
2,800 compounds about half of which are
trans approved in the US and about a
quarter of which are drugs approved in
Canada UK Europe and Japan and then
about a quarter of these compounds are
investigational drugs that were used in
clinical trials so this image shows
high-throughput screening facilities and
in cats and again we use the
methyltransferase Clos acid in order to
screen sixteen thousand two hundred
fifty-one compounds and three doses we
chose 115 micro molar 57 and a half
micro molar an 11-point live micro molar
and the performance of the screen was
excellent among 43 1536 well plates the
average C prime factor value was 0.92
which is actually very similar to the C
prime of the optimized assay our average
signal to background ratio for the 43
plates was above 3 and we use C MSL
control percent coefficient of variation
is kind of an indicator of variability
and liquid handling and we like this
value to be below 10% and as you can see
the average percent coefficient of
variation was 1.7 which was excellent
and we had a three point three percent
Henry so among the hints we chose to
follow up on 289 compounds is
cherry-picks and this figure shows on
the left the compound storage facility
it's a negative twenty freezer that
contains robotics inside and can't
deliver the compounds to the window
shown in the centre and then they're
plated out
at eleven point concentration series so
that we can follow up and not only
confirm the activity of these hits but
also get a better indication of their
potency
advocacy's so to do this we utilize the
methyltransferase glow assay again and
you can see the schematic for that shown
on this slide and 174 compounds were
confirmed as hits we repeated this assay
11-point dose response so here are four
of the heads and it'll become clear why
I'm introducing these four they each
have a different story
so this first compound was actually
synthesized at in cats and I'll talk
more about that soon the second compound
is known as cz nap it's a carboxylic
analogue of adenosine and it's known as
a global has its own methylation
inhibitor the the compound on the lower
left is ketosis on which I mentioned is
known inhibitor and Institute so we were
delighted that this showed up as ahead
because it really validated our
screening approach and then this
compound on the lower right is known as
a CBC 25 phosphatase inhibitor it
inhibits the three CBC 25 isoforms with
the animal of potencies so this was not
knoin to inhibit NSD - the first thing
that we wanted to do was ask whether any
of these compounds were actually
inhibiting the acid readout and may not
actually have any genuine activity
against the annecy - enzyme and in order
to do this we performed a counter screen
where we added the concentration of saw
that we would expect in the uninhibited
NSC to reaction and we incubated that
saw with test compounds and then perform
the detection readout measured
luminescent light so with the four
compounds I introduced we saw the
following as you can see the two
compounds shown in the bottom showed no
apparent interference with the acid
readout but the new compounds shown at
the top appeared to inhibit the assay
and the dose response occurs pretty much
overlapped the initial observation
suggesting that maybe all the activity
that we're observing
estudio interference with the primary
assay so we actually the the compound in
the upper left was not a huge surprise
as I mentioned this was synthesized at
in cats and it was actually synthesized
to demonstrate that it inhibited firefly
the suffering so it contains in red the
PTC 124 Wyatt e this was actually a PTC
124 is a drug indicated for Duchenne
muscular dystrophy and it was developed
by PTC therapeutics and it was
identified with the firefly luciferase
reporter assay and so this was used in
in a nonsense codon suppression assay
and they identified PTC 1:24 and a group
of n cats
demonstrated that this is a potent
inhibitor of fire flightless separates
this compound synthesized and shown to
interact with the luciferase with a very
high very strong affinity dissociation
constant of 120 pika molar and
crystallographic studies show the direct
interaction between this compound and
firefly the severance well we still
followed up on this finding it as you
can see with the data shown in the black
circles and as expected this compound
totally inhibited firefly luciferase and
you might be wondering why there's such
a shift in potency between the fire
flightless if very sassy and our methyl
transferase low assay and this is
because even though the methyl
transferase glow assay utilized a
firefly with Sepphoris enzyme it was a
genetically evolved version with a
number of amino acid substitutions that
made it more thermal stable and less
susceptible to inhibition by test
compounds food the acid was really
intended to support high-throughput
screening so that's why you can see the
shift in potency now notably the DZ nap
compound that also interfered with this
assay showed no evidence of interfering
with firefly luciferase
so it's likely interfering with
another one of the enzymes the couple
saw to luminescent light so the next
question we had was given we confirm the
activity of 174 compounds and then after
performing the counter screen to
identify compounds they also inhibited
the primary assay we had a hundred
thirty-seven comments that at least
appeared at that point to be selected
towards NSC - we were aware that many of
these compound libraries were
pharmacologically active and contained
reactive compound so we formed a neo
plex read assay to identify compounds
that are just reactive in might say have
a unwanted mechanism of inhibiting
Manistee - so with the amp lex red-ass a
redox cycling compounds can interact
with dtt to generate hydrogen peroxide
and then horseradish peroxidase is able
to convert an plex reddit in hydrogen
peroxide to resolution it can be
measured in a plate reader by reading
fluorescence now you might recognize
this compound shown at the top right
part of this slide as the fourth
compound I introduced you as a hit from
the high-throughput screen and in fact
Johnson and colleagues in 2008 reported
this is very reactive compound here are
their data and their data match our
findings with our amp Lex red assay
which are shown in red squares and you
can see that for the G a300 3 molecule
the potency of this reactivity mears the
potency of the NSC to inhibition
suggesting that probably the mechanism
is due to the reactivity of this
compound and none of the other compounds
showed any evidence of a growing redox
cycling so at this point we really
wanted to gain additional evidence for
on target activity that these compounds
are actually inhibiting the activity of
NSC 2 so we turn to an orthogonal assay
approach we utilize
time-resolved förster resonance energy
transfer TR Fred and this is very
similar to standard Fred
it's a proximity based assay where with
when the two components are within 20
nanometers proximity there could be a
non radiative energy transfer between
the donor and acceptor you can measure a
friend said well in this case the donor
is a lanthanide that can have a long
emission a lifetime up to a millisecond
and this is really well suited for
high-throughput screening because often
there are sources of unwanted
fluorescence following the excitation
including like proteins and compounds
and serum and so this is unwanted
fluorescence drops off quickly but the
long emission time of the Lamb tonight
allows you to measure that time resolve
red signal later on after that one of
the lines in fluorescence it's decayed
and additionally it's possible to
measure not only the time result red
signal but the donor emission which can
sometimes indicate compounds that are
interfering with your assay
so the way this assay was set up it said
there was an anti saw crept date so
antibody containing the lanthanide and
then it binds to a labeled saw enabling
a high fret signal to be read in the
absence of any methyl transferase
activity
so as the methyl transferase reaction is
proceeding unlabelled saw then goes in
just places the labeled form of this sod
resulting in a reduced HT RF signal so
you can see the optimized assay shown on
the right with the full reaction as you
would expect having lower signal
compared to the new enzyme control and
you can see that the overall acid
parameters are very similar to the
methyl transferase glow acid and be
optimized with the C prime close to
point nine and a signal to background
above 3 so we did verify that this assay
it is tolerant 2d in the cell by
conducting a TMS o titration as you can
see in this slide and then we proceeded
to evaluate the hundred and four heads
that were confirmed with the primary
assay did not interfere with that ass
we did not find any evidence that they
were redox cycling compounds and of
these hundred and four compounds that we
had at that point we confirmed the
activity of 48 compounds and so what
happened with the four compounds that I
introduced to you well it turns out that
there was no evidence for inhibition of
NSC two by the two compounds shown at
the top okay
but the both acute Ellison and T 8300
three didn't show evidence of inhibiting
Manistee too
so at this point we wanted to evaluate
the activity of these 40 remaining
compounds against the two clinically
relevant mutants that we had developed
assays for again the methyl transferase
below assay so we first screened these
14 heads against the 1099 K point
mutation and you can see that 45 of the
48 heads also also inhibited that mutant
including these two shown here at the
bottom ketosis N and he 8300 3 as shown
in the purple triangles and then we
evaluated the t 1150 a mutation and we
found them 44 the 48 MSC to wild-type
inhibitor compounds also inhibited this
view and you can see that the potency is
of both acute Ellison and T a303 against
the two mutants essentially overlapped
okay so ultimately we decided to follow
up on five compounds and two of them
I've already described to you
I can't Ellison we decided to continue
to follow because it was a known NSC to
inhibitor and so we wanted to keep it as
a positive control the other compound T
in three zero zero three we thought its
activity was due to chemical reactivity
was she's a nine desirable mechanism but
we still wanted to continue to see how
it performed in our downstream NASA's
the other three kind of models I've not
describes you yet and they include that
a bt 199
Benigno clacks it's so divine bcl-2 with
some animal or affinities and it's been
approved by the FDA for treatment of CLL
this compound called TCL PK 5 4 was
reported by Sanofi as those selected
with LP a 5 receptor antagonist and the
spider compound is known as a highly
potent or corticoid receptor antagonist
so the first thing we wanted to do was
by now that we had two different
activity assays suggesting that these
compounds interacted with an inhibited
NSC - we wanted to really carefully
measure their activity against Tennesse
- so we chose the most sensitive and and
kind of gold standard assay or aware of
which is a radial label Sam a saying and
this has a sensitivity of the radio
label but it also is a direct measure of
the nucleosome product of the methylated
product so this is an excellent assay
and as you can see from our data all
five of these compounds inhibited NSD -
according to this a savory down as well
so now we have three orthogonal readouts
of activity all indicating that these
compounds are able to inhibit annecy -
and at the bottom right you can see that
we use the size and control that's known
to inhibit NSC - at around eight micro
molar so this table summarizes the data
thus far and you can see that the
potencies of all five compounds were
very similar with that methyl
transferase flow ese between the
wild-type and mutant enzymes for reasons
we don't understand the a300 3 and can't
ellison seem to be much less potent
against NSC - according to the HTR FSA
and then again for reasons we don't
understand the radio labeled activity
assay indicated that all 5 compounds
were substantially more potent
inhibitors of NSC - than either the
first two assays suggested however
this is as I said the most sensitive
readout of activity and also a direct
measure of the methylated nucleus on
product and so we repeated these studies
of number of times and I would say that
we have most confidence in these numbers
so given that we had three different
assays suggesting that these compounds
were able inhibit NST to wanting to ask
a question of whether they're able to
bind to the cattle and accept domain as
we would expect
and so we perform surface plasmon
resonance experiments and this is our
controls both saw and sam bound the
catalytic set domain of NSC - as
expected on so it turns out that all
five of our follow-up compounds also
bound to the central main of an estate -
as you can see with these dissociation
constant values on the right I want to
highlight that for the compounds bounce
stoichiometrically so one inhibitor to
one catalytic set domain she told us
about super stoichiometrically so there
were multiple ketosis in molecules
percent domain and this was actually
expected based on literature that
indicates that they thought my binds of
ketosis and can form covalent addicts on
to proteins and we suspect that this is
actually the mechanism of inhibition of
ketosis and for n SC - it's forming
these covalent addicts and in
interfering with its activity okay so
it's also interesting to consider the
affinities of these compounds to the set
domain and how closely they compare to
the activities that we determined using
the radio labeled a saying as I'm
showing in the far right you can see
that these are often within two or three
for activity ic50 values compared to the
dissociation constant so this is the way
we felt confident that these compounds
by three different assays were
inhibiting annecy - they were binding
catalytic site domain we wanted to ask
were they selected for NSD too and so we
profiled 30 of methyltransferases and
I'm the first column on the left I'm
showing you the name of the
methyltransferase
the next column I'm showing you the
substrate and then the next five columns
are each inhibitor and I'm indicating
the activity in micro molar units and
I'm coloring these cells as a heat map
with green indicating very potent
inhibition red indicating very weak
inhibition and then white indicating no
inhibition observed and what you can see
is that the most potent and least
selective compound was T 8300 three and
it's pretty striking when you compare
that to cheat ellison which is known as
a you know universal methyl transferase
inhibitor you can see that da three zero
zero three is quite a bit more Universal
I would say that the most selective
inhibitor here is the Pfizer compound
but it's not selected for NSC - it seems
somewhat selected of course several
other methyl transferases so none of
these compounds are selective towards
NSC - but nevertheless we had
demonstrated that they can inhibit NSC -
activity and they bound the catalytic
site to me so we wanted to ask a
question of whether we can find evidence
that they were inhibiting NS t - in
cells and so we utilize - you - OS
osteosarcoma cells and had been
previously reported that if you use an
SI RNA to knock down the concentrations
of NS T 2 you get as expected a
reduction in h3k 3610 methylation so we
wanted to apply our compounds to these
cells and see if the levels of H 3 king
36 by methylation dropped and that assay
is shown here at the top of the Western
on the left side of the slide you can
see that we use T XenApp as a control
our collaborator is a reaction biology
perform these experiments and experience
what the cell linemen were aware that
easy
that would be an excellent control for
age three kid 36 and methylation
inhibition and we measure densitometry
here and plot in it on the right and the
black circles you can see that we
estimated it policy of 319 animal and we
don't think that that's due to
inhibition of NSD 2 because I showed you
that in vitro activity data that
indicated that this is not able to
inhibit NSD 2 so must be by some other
mechanism another thing that we noticed
in conducting these studies was that all
of these compounds to some extent at
least the highest concentrations were
toxic to cells and so we performed a
proliferation as I shown at the right
side of the slide and the bottom over 96
hours and you can see we use bortezomib
as and control there's various amounts
of toxicity in different concentrations
on the left side of the slide you can
see that we're blotting h3k 3610
methylation and a total histone for
reading and you can see the reductions
in h3k 36 by methylation but we didn't
want to consider conditions where we
knew there was also cytotoxicity because
they could kind of found our data so if
we only considered conditions where
there's no evidence of toxicity for
these compounds I would say that the
only compound the suggestions of dose
dependent increases in age 30k 3610
methylation with the Pfizer compound
which is shown with the green triangles
on top with a parent potency of about 3
points you micro molar now it's unclear
whether that's due to NSC - or not
because the profiling data also
indicated that it can hit a variety of
different enzymes
so in summary NSE 2 is a
well-established target for cancer
therapeutics but it's been a very
difficult target and so far no one has
reported high droop on screen using
full-length wild-type
Manistee - and a nucleosome substrate so
we were able to utilize the methyl
transferase flow luminescence assay to
screen 16,000 251 compounds at 3 doses
and I
identified a number of his-- we followed
up by 289 of those hits and confirms
activities of some in 11-point
dose-response format and then confirmed
active compounds we interrogated them
with a variety of China and orthogonal
assays including the gold standard radio
label assay and we followed up on the
activity of five inhibitors and confirm
their interaction with the catalytic set
domain using surface plasmon resonance
and we evaluated the selectivity of
these five inhibitors and showed that
none of them were selective towards
tennyson - however the Pfizer compound
showed some hint of activity in cell
based assays but it's unclear yet
whether that's due to inhibition of NS
t2 or another enzyme like in the case of
T XenApp but I think what we really did
here was we developed a very nice
workflow for the identification of
selective MSC 2 inhibitors and we need
to screen different chemical libraries
and so that's currently the plan we're
currently seeking funding took the form
of a large I throughput screen using
some of the other library collections
that we have and in the meantime are
currently performing structural studies
of NS t 2 in complex with substrates and
some of the inhibitors we identified and
we plan to perform in silico screening
identify in silico heads among compounds
in our own libraries in house and then
follow up by these hits using a in vitro
assays I want to acknowledge a number of
colleagues who contributed to these
studies including my colleagues at
reaction biology and n cats and I want
to thank you for your attention
thank you dr. cousins for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window take your question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button once there's
many of your questions as we
you have time for so let's get started
our first question is you perform the
high-throughput screen the
high-throughput screen using full-length
wild-type at sd2 could you have carried
out the screen with one of the mutant
enzymes instead yes great question so we
did perform the screen with the
wild-type NSD two enzyme but I showed
you the data that indicated that the
acid performance with the two mutant
enzymes was very similar and we were
able to obtain the mutant enzymes in
sufficient quantity or high-throughput
screening actually one of the I
mentioned that we are currently seeking
funding to perform a larger screen and
we are actually considering using the
e10 99k point you for the screen instead
of well Tennessee to our next question
is what was the assay used to measure
activities for the methyl transferase
profiling studies okay so all of these
asks of the methyl transferase profiling
work was done with the radio labeled
assay and dr. cousins it looks like we
have time for one more question you use
nucleosomes extract them from the HeLa
cells as a substrate but there could be
heterogeneity from pre-existing
modifications would it have been better
to use homogeneous recombinant
nucleosomes assembled from purified
histones
yeah that's an excellent question and we
thought about that question pretty hard
obviously the advantage of having
defined substrates is see you have a lot
more knowledge about you know what's
going into the acid but ultimately we
felt that the nucleosomes is purified
from heal our more physiologically
relevant substrate and I showed you that
data that indicates NS C 2 is more
active against native histones purified
from HeLa so we really thought that that
was ultimately the better way to go
thanks for the question I'd like to once
again thank dr. cousins for his
presentation I would also like to thank
lab birds for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through August of
2018 you will receive an email from
labyrinth letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon goodbye